why are they supporting him well
politics is a weird game and it you know
strange bedfellows and you have to
protect your ass it's like a constant
protection racket with everybody but the
thing is he is breaking down at
extraordinary
at an extraordinary rate there was uh
well i'm gonna show you some video from
friday and we could have i could have
spent the next hour
uh showing you clips of him being unable
to read say things sensibly we're just
gonna pick a couple things here's here
he is struggling with the prompter
it is noteworthy that the percentage of
women who registered to vote and cast a
ballot is consistently higher than the
percentage of the men who do so end of
quote repeat the line
women are not without electoral and or
political or or maybe precisely not
andor or political power
end of quote repeat the lie the men who
do so end of quote repeat the line look
i fumble words sometimes when i'm doing
this as i often tell you guys i have a
prompter in front of me that doesn't
tell me what to say it just says the
order of the show right so it tells me
like what's coming up next what clip am
i throwing to the rest of this is coming
out of my brain what's more interesting
than him reading end of quote repeat the
line
is that he basically has been reduced
to an elderly man who just reads
pretty poorly off a teleprompter he does
not know what he is saying he often
rampages through these things stumbling
and stammering and doesn't pick up all
of the things that he knocked down right
like he doesn't actually realize that
he's made all of these mistakes he says
all of these random things then he tells
us that he's not allowed to talk and
that he's going to get in trouble and
they don't want him to talk and a whole
bunch of other stuff
here he is on the bike again this
weekend he didn't fall off this time
that's pretty good
some of the groups want i don't look
like a fool here in this interview
but i put a helmet on because it's a
tough interview
but all kids aside i think that uh
all right whatever it's not such a big
deal about the helmet it's just that he
just doesn't know what he's doing and
it's like the image of that him standing
there mocking himself for the helmet do
you think any other world leaders are
afraid of this guy do you think they
honestly think he's in charge
like does anyone really believe that any
of this is working can you picture
uh what obama or trump would have done
in that situation like
i mean come on you guys got it but then
there's this other thing where he just
doesn't know what he's doing right and
again he's the pilot of the plane if you
think of the country as a plane right
and you want even if you don't like
exactly the direction that the plane is
going right you want to land there but
they want to go this way you roughly
want the plane to land you don't want
the plane to burst
into flames mid-air you don't want the
plane to go down into the into the ditch
so i would like things to be better here
here's a couple images that we got from
twitter this is from rnc research these
are the notes they zoomed in on the
notes that they often hand joe biden now
i get it people have notes he has to
remember names he has to remember
locations all sorts of stuff that is
just fine however we zoomed into one of
these things let's take a look at this
you enter the roosevelt room and say
hello to participants you take your seat
press enters you give brief comments
press departs you ask liz schuler
president afl-cio a question you
thank participants you depart with you
in capital letters because he is not
sure who he
is
this is a problem
this is a big problem
you